[Music]
and no pool party news wha-why no party
nobody
I love pool party admitted by exploding
Bubba oh yeah
a woman was rescued from her pool after
posting for help on Facebook way she had
enough time to type honored bush on a
floaty phone but she she was drowning
with the cellphone I imagined her on the
floor he's like she probably drowned
because she was [ __ ] on her phone she
drowned she was in the middle of
drowning no she didn't she lied I know
she's a hot girl and she was like
someone saved me someone came and saved
her this is Leslie she's 61 years old
from New Hampshire pretty hot okay girl
Leslie what happen to Leslie are you a
trouble as me so Leslie was swimming in
her pool why she drew her foot got stuck
on a ladder and as she was trying to get
out of her pool cuz it looks like she
lives in oh the ladder fell out the
ladder broke that's how you killed the
Sims ugly Sims if you put him in you put
him in a pool you take the ladder up
they swim until there he's Austin they
fall asleep and they die in the pool and
the Grim Reaper comes Oh
happen to real life I don't even know
we're talking about because she's too
heavy to like yeah so she doesn't have
like that much upper body strength
hmm and so she looks like she got a lot
of upper-body strength though she got
bigger biceps to me
well they mentioned that she's a breast
cancer survivor so maybe that she had
breast cancer but she still got titties
probably weak like her she's not like
they took out the tumor I don't know
exactly the details of her past cancer
history but I think she was probably
saying maybe because of treatments or
something that you later buddy
so she ended up getting stuck her phone
was left inside of her home she was home
alone so she was just like so meaning
like thinking like now what do I do
how deep is that thing she can't just
stand oh so she couldn't do one of these
like
she couldn't do one of those she was
stuck in her pool for three hours Wow
oh my gosh she must've been pruney yeah
that's good she went swimming on her
cell with her cellphone though she did
it it was in the house yeah so she
didn't have my cell phone right so after
all that time in the pool then she
remembered that she had her iPad nearby
on a chair so she used this yeah and so
she ended up grabbing that pole and she
pulled the chair closer she was able to
reach over for the iPad that's when she
dawned on her three hours that's she got
on Facebook on and then she posted on
her community page she wrote this dream
9-1-1 my pool ladder broke while I was
trying to get out of the pool home alone
phone is inside I need something to
bring me tools and help me change the
steps so I can get out of the pool I'm
serious I don't have the agility to
climb out any other way Hunter Drive I
like how it's perfectly grammatically
correction capitalizes periods Wow well
that's what Apple does if you do space
based so if you go period space based
that it automatically capitalizes for
you MA she would have been [ __ ] up I
would have mad typos when how many
people responded whole community started
like commenting back like oh my gosh are
you okay like what can we do or whatever
so then finally there was a lady that
lived a couple Street from her and so
she ended up showing up at her house
that's when Leslie sent her inside to go
get the toolbox and then after that
police showed up and after the neighbors
saw that police were at her house the
neighbor showed up and so everyone was
like trying to help her and then it
became a pool party she's lucky that I'm
not her neighbor out of just drove my
car straight into a swimming pool to
save her ass I'm looking for an
adventure so I'm like oh [ __ ] this is a
movie scene and then I'll grab her ass
and [ __ ] drag her ass out and even
though she's like I'm conscious of life
but no [ __ ] I'm giving you CPR
I know imagine does Barney's biggest
expense just run right into it you said
you needed saving and you [ __ ]
shooting holes in the [ __ ] pool it's
all like slightly peaking Apple he gets
[ __ ] explosive [ __ ] first answer
you're welcome citizen who just walks up
aisle ball hanging by your [ __ ] car
don't worry
catmus really strapped look at c4 is
around the tree get a big [ __ ] net if
we had millions of dollars we can do
skits like that you just cause like
$200,000 worth of damage to save a cat
that's awesome cuz it's the life that
matters the worst heroes ever you need
to write this idea down that'd be so
dope you're gonna that's all I was
telling you at the restaurants when you
say can you watch my purse I like how
the waiting was I'm gonna take that
first I know what I'm gonna rip your
person do Dobby so buddy they're like
hey I somehow lock myself in my house I
don't know what to do Bartz like I do
and he [ __ ] rammed his car inside of
the [ __ ] front the living room
he drives back down we come in we
started knocking down the house hey
everyone but part in joke
that's fine oh my god would you guys
create like a team kind of a team oh my
god there's a there's a team of [ __ ]
dumbass and these water see for some
dumbass food I'll be so sick every
episode is like a problem it would be so
annoying to watch those it's like it's
like like Amelia Bedelia my mailbox is
[ __ ] stuck and then here you come too
[ __ ] dumb asses and they just [ __ ] it
I'd be so frustrated no but then the
person that's calling for help they're
really frantic though they're really
need help I help the lady out of the
wall that's her concern right she
couldn't get on the poor helped her out
with this and I [ __ ] blasted that
stupid ladder that was sabotage I mean
what are we gonna do when someone's like
reroofing everything and then their
ladder just Falls and they're like [ __ ]
how am I gonna get down now teach the
[ __ ] ladder a lesson you blast a hole
in the roof until they could come down
yeah you destroy the home so the roof
can come down safely so he could walk
off he'd fly a helicopter and landed on
the roof the story happened what do you
do when someone has a flat tire call
triple-a we don't need to help
that's under our pavement that's
different culture boy always [ __ ] up
right there they both looked at me like
I'm a [ __ ] idiot
it's not life or death Geo
the type of cases that we handle is like
imagine you're walking to get water in
the middle of the night right you stub
your pinky toe on the couch a [ __ ]
couch that's when we break it and the
[ __ ] flame thrower the [ __ ] couch
for [ __ ] you're hurting your toes yep
that's the kind that we leave him ago
I've saved you miss and we go you're
welcome citizen you're welcome so then
you're my sticker tire you wouldn't
punish the street or whoever like that
that's a everyday thing that's like hey
I need help
oil change use Google yeah you know yeah
that's your fault you don't know
everyday [ __ ] you know but it's not
every day that a lady gets stuck in her
own pool
what if a little old lady fellows you
can't get up that [ __ ] has got problems
if she can't get up and that's her fault
we got those button teasin like don't
you just like those emergency it's not
working so you go to that company blow
up a company save her malfunctioning no
but if a lady is in a car and she's like
drowning like that in a car yeah like
she's in a car like let's say it's like
yeah like that then I have no other
choice but to go down there rig some c4
bombs on the car so the car flies back
out and then lads back on the ground
only and we only have like 30 seconds to
do it so you have to dive in really fast
and we start making sure putting the c-4
in the right place I'm imagining if
someone locked themselves out of the
house they'd blow up like a huge or the
rest of the house and then go behind the
door and unlock it and that's that's the
d-squad way goodies but I probably also
fart in the car so she has oxygen to
breathe first
kill her I think she'd rather diet no
because she's running out of air at the
cars going on no I knew children that's
geological friends it's like a airborne
ivy you know all the nutrients given to
system let's say someone is hiking in
the tundra and they get lost and they're
like help like remember that guy that
got caught in the in the ice thing and
he used Facebook like help me I'm in the
middle of there right like so we'll pull
them out wrap them around with the
fireproof oil and [ __ ] blow torches
ass yeah
yep that's the fastest way to thaw
someone out I hope you guys enjoy this
video for more please subscribe to our
Channel and you can check out the last
video right here
[Applause]